this is a production of cornell
university
so i put up the uh probably what's
familiar to all of you
um probably the most reproduced graph in
all of science
which shows the inexorable warming uh
increase in the carbon dioxide
concentration in the atmosphere which is
warming the climate and we all know that
the source of
this carbon dioxide is the burning of
fossil fuels coal and oil and gas
less familiar to
to many people
is how important the role of forests is
in the global carbon budget
this is a diagram from the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change
maybe the arrows on your keyboard tim
not responding
down at the yeah
down at the perfect well this is a this
is a diagram from the intergovernmental
panel on climate change
and i just wanted to point out uh the
role of
forests in carbon storage and and flow
these are units of
what are called gigatons of carbon and
in the boxes are the amount of stock of
carbon
in different parts of the earth
so on the lower left we see terrestrial
ecosystems
contain about 2 500 gigatons of carbon
and it's a comparable amount of carbon
as is in fossil fuel reserves
there's a lot of carbon and most of this
is in the trees
and in the forest soils
second thing i wanted to point out is
the
important role of deforestation mostly
in the tropical countries
in adding carbon dioxide to the
atmosphere
shown on the left side with the arrow
and also the large roll of mostly
temperate forests
in absorbing some of that carbon dioxide
so the carbon dioxide concentration in
the atmosphere is going up a little bit
more slowly than it would be
if the forests weren't increasing in
their stock
i wanted to begin
by just having you think for a moment
about a particular forest that's
familiar to you think about
how the forest say out in your back
forty or
up on the hillside above your your
village or town
um where'd it come from how did he get
there even if it has some big trees in
it you can see some big trees here in an
old growth
northern hardwood forest see the person
there for scale
even if it has big trees it's pro unless
you happen to be from the central
adirondacks
it's probably not an old growth forest
that is it's been cut down in the past
and then grown back
so we have second growth or third growth
forests throughout most of the northeast
except a few little pockets of preserves
so most of the northeastern united
states
was deforested originally
the landscape was entirely covered with
trees almost 99
of the northeastern united states would
have been forested naturally
one picture is worth a thousand words
this is a picture from newfield new york
just south of ithaca
taken in 1870 and you can see the
covered bridge down in the lower right
there
and all the hillsides are completely
deforested
go to the same location in 2015 there's
that same bridge
and there are trees everywhere
so this graph shows the history of
changes in the amount of forest land
area in the state of new york as i say
before 1600 it was almost entirely
forested
after european settlement the amount of
forest land
decreased the area was logged over
a lot of it was converted to agriculture
and pastures
reaching a minimum amount of forest
cover around the turn of the 19
1900s
since then
reforestation has occurred on many areas
so that now we have a landscape that's
predominantly forested
so most of the forests that we have now
actually originated about a hundred
years ago
their second growth
post-flogging forests like this northern
hardwood forest
or forests that have grown back on
abandoned fields and pastures
like these forests most of the forest
uh
of fields and pastures occurred during
the early part of the 20th century when
marginal agriculture was abandoned
also in the 1930s
the civilian conservation corps planted
a lot of conifers on abandoned
agricultural lands
so we have a variety of forests in terms
of their age
their composition
the condition of the forest the history
of its management
they all provide a variety of services
to society
they're valued for timber for lumber
products
valued for aesthetics and recreation the
value for
wildlife habitat for clean water and now
we realize that they're also valuable
for storing carbon
and in
in essence global climate change
mitigation
so my objective for this session this
morning
is to
describe for you some general principles
regarding this value the services
provided by carmen
storage in forests
i'm not going to give you prescriptions
for the manager management of particular
forests
i'm not really qualified to do that i'm
an ecologist i'm like an armchair
professor many of you are much more
expert on forest management than i am
and you know that each parcel
that you're thinking about managing
requires a specific prescription plan
that depends on its condition its
history its composition depends on the
objectives of the landowners
rather what i'm going to try to i'm not
going to give you prescriptions i'm
going to try to explain
in principle how
forests are related to global climate
change and carbon mitigation and
hopefully there'll be some useful
information for you to apply
uh in a management or a policy context
i thought it might be helpful for you
for me to
give you a preview of the topics that
we'll cover in the order in which
they'll be covered the first one i've
already covered
the variety of northeastern forests
next i'll make an important distinction
between
forest carbon stocks and the forest
sequestration process
and i'll explain a
general principle regarding maximization
of climate change mitigation with
forests
then i'll explain
how in the absence of management a
developing forest
will
store carbon and how the sequestration
rate will change over time
under no management
those forest stocks though are always
under
some risk of disturbance natural
disturbances and we'll describe briefly
some of the disturbances and what the
implications of disturbance are for the
permanence of forest carbon stocks
then i'll give you some general
considerations about silviculture and
management for climate mitigation and
adaptation
followed by a little bit about
deforestation
of
mostly post-agricultural deforested land
its potential in some of the challenges
there
and i'll end by talking for a bit about
forest products
and maybe i'll say a few words about
forest woody biofuels and then i'll give
you some take-home messages so that's
the sequence you can jump out or jump in
uh as you see fit from these topics
we'll cover them over about a 45 minute
period
okay so first the distinction between
forest carbon stocks and forest carbon
sequestration rate
so forced carbon stocks defined on the
right here
are the mass of carbon per unit of
ground area
the amount of carbon stored in the trees
and in the
soils so it'd be say tons per acre or
hectare
about half of the biomass the dry mass
of a tree is carbon
so that's the relationship between
biomass or mass of the tree and
the carbon stock
carbon sequestration is a process it's
the rate at which carbon accumulates in
those trees as a result of
photosynthetic
carbon fixation
incorporating that carbon into the
biomass of the tree
a key principle
that i'll try to point out a couple of
times is the
position of durable wood products
harvested from a forest as a carbon
stock
so this carbon that's harvested from a
forest it's no longer in the forest
but the carbon in those trees is not
released to the atmosphere rather it's
in a building or it's in some
durable form
okay not all of what we harvest
from the from the forest goes into
durable products a lot of it is returned
back to the atmosphere as carbon dioxide
as it breaks down
this is the carbon stock
for a typical northern hardwood forest
jenny mentioned that i work at a place
called hubbard brook experimental forest
so this is a forest it's a fairly
typical second growth hardwood forest
it was heavily logged in 1910 so it's
about 90 years old over 90 years old
and the about half of the carbon a
little bit less than half the carbon is
in the living trees
here it shows 9 000 or so grams of
carbon per square meter ground area
and another 2 500 grams of carbon in the
roots of the trees
a little over half of the carbon in the
forest is in the soil either on the
surface in the organic forest floor
or down in the mineral soil
and then there's always some
woody debris that
lies around and slowly decaying
i want to say a few words specifically
about the soil
carbon soil carbon is typically more
than half of the carbon stored as a
stock in a forest around here
however it's not very dynamic
so it's the brown stuff you see
when you dig a hole in the ground
that's a high in soil carbon
but as i say it's not very dynamic what
i mean by that is that the stock of
carbon in the soil changes very slowly
we studied this in some great detail we
studied forest carbon in great detail at
hubbard brook
when we did a whole tree harvest
experiment back in 1980s
so in the whole tree harvest you cut
down the trees and you take all the wood
away including the tops of the trees
so this is a situation that should have
its maximum effect on soil carbonates or
like a worst case scenario for losing
soil carbon because for a long period of
time there's no carbon being added and
you're losing a lot of carbon
this graphic shows the results of that
experiment as well as some models
first the two curves there the blue line
and the red dotted line
are
simulations using one of the most widely
used computer models for projecting
changes in soil carbon we were studying
how global climate change
might affect
soil carbon
and maybe in relationship to forest
management so we parameterized these
models for harvard brook for which we
know a lot of information
and then evaluated their performance
against the observations the
observations are for this whole tree
harvest experiment
so the data here are the dots
and the error bars are shown there
so after we cut the forest at time zero
the amount of carbon that we measured in
the forest when soil went down slightly
though not statistically significantly
after
about five years
after ten or so years we could actually
detect a slight decline in the amount of
carbon there you can see the error bars
don't overlap
but then it looked like it had come back
by the time you get out to 15 or 20
years and you can see the models didn't
really
fit the observations all that well
the point i'm really most
uh most making here
is that the changes in carbon that are
associated with this extreme uh
treatment of poultry harvest are pretty
small
and probably that's a maximum that you
would ever see in a treatment
and to measure those stocks changes
was an enormous undertaking
we had a crew of a crew of students out
there all summer
digging pits in the ground and measuring
how much carbon was in the soil in each
of those pits we had 60 pits
that were dug on each date
and you can see what the error bars look
like
so we could barely detect it
it's very hard to measure precisely
so from the standpoint of accounting for
carbon it's probably not a good idea
to require for auditing purposes the
measurement of soil carbon changes
they're going to be small
and
they're going to be hard to hard to
measure
which brings me to a key principle
which is shown in bold on the upper
right here
so i won't read through it but the key
point here is that any carbon that's not
in the forest
is in the atmosphere
trapping heat all the time that carbon
dioxide molecule is up there in the
atmosphere it's trapping heat so the
goal is
from forest management standpoint
to maximize the total stock of carbon
through time
to keep as much carbon as possible in
the trees and in the forest through time
but we would include in this stock
the harvested products that go into
durable products like buildings like
that log cabin
now this is kind of a simplified view of
things
and it's complicated
by one important
clarification and that is what time
how long should we be thinking about
it says time integrated time integrated
over what time horizon you can make a
pretty good case
that the carbon stored in a forest today
and in the near future
is more valuable than it will be
in the long distance
future
basically the reason for this is that
most people are technological optimists
the human ingenuity by the end of this
century or in the next century sometime
is going to come up with solutions
to climate change that are safe
and cheap they're not available now
and so anything that we do now to make
to keep carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere is more important to us
than keeping carbon in the atmos dioxide
out of the atmosphere at the end of the
century we're all going to have
cold fusion packs in our back pocket by
the end of the century you can see that
this is somewhat to somewhat uh
a subjective judgment if you're an
optimist about technology that's what
you'd say if you're pessimistic about
technology you'd say well it's going to
be just as important in the future
um
this though
has an influence on your carbon
management on the planning for carbon
the fact that
my claim that carbon is more valuable in
the short run in the forest than in the
wrong run
maybe a bit controversial but and i'm
happy to
address questions on that at the end
next i'm going to go through
in the absence of management when a
forest is growing back after being
disturbed how the carbon stocks would be
expected to change
so after logging or after a blow down
this is a graph in which the vertical
axis shows the carbon sequestration rate
the rate at which carbon is accumulating
in the forest
through time
so it's the rate of stock change
at the beginning right after the forest
has been logged over or blown down
um
this we had a we had a
microburst event at harvard brook that
knocked down about 100 acres of forest
i'm glad i wasn't out there must have
been terrifying but all the trees were
knocked down over about 108 hectare area
100 acre area
so initially
those trees are decomposing and adding
co2 to the atmosphere
so the sequestration rate is negative
forest is a carbon source
but after about 25 years the trees are
now growing back fast and much of their
organic matter is decayed and the forest
will accumulate carbon at a faster and
faster rate for several decades usually
peaking
at around age 50 75 maybe 100 years
depending on the site
species composition or what have you
after that the sequestration rate will
go down
until it approaches zero maybe typically
around here maybe at 150
170
years of age
at that point
we reach a condition so-called carbon
saturation there's no
additional carbon accumulating at that
location
because the trees are still growing but
trees are dying and decomposing as fast
as the trees that are there or growing
i want to give you an example from a
particular forest
fairly typical for this for the for our
region it's the arnott forest which is a
several thousand acre
forest forested area owned by cornell
just south of ithaca
it was heavily logged over in the late
19th century
and in the early 20th century
some cornell professors set up some
permanent plots
in that forest and measured all the
trees so we can calculate how much
carbon there was in that oh roughly 40
year old forest in the year 1933
and the forest hasn't been managed since
when i arrived in the 1980s
cornell i found the records for these
stands and we went out and relocated the
plots and tagged all the trees and
in 25 or so one acre plots
and we've measured them six times since
so you can see those green dots are the
measurements so the force has been
accumulating carbon it roughly doubled
between 1930s and 1980s when i arrived
the red dotted line
shows
the trend for a computer model
projecting the carbon stocks
in the trees
through time and you can see it works
very well it almost perfectly matches
the observations
and so we can make an expectation or
projection of the future carbon stock
as it will change over the next 50 or 70
years and it'll reach a peak sometime in
the late 20th 21st century
so the carbon stock is large and
slightly increasing still through the
century
on the other hand the carbon
sequestration rate in the absence of
management is decreasing
so the force is approaching carbon
saturation by the end of the century
so we will have this large carbon stock
with a slower smaller sink strengths
that carbon stock isn't guaranteed to be
here
at the end of the century
because it could be affected by natural
disturbances and so i'll just say a few
words about
permanence of forest carbon stocks and
risks
to forest carbon that permanence
the risks of the security of forest
carbon stocks are from natural forces
like forest fires they're not very
important in the eastern united states
much more important out west because
it's so wet around here
the ones that are important to us are
storms severe storms and pests and
pathogens
severe storms like this microburst storm
so that
carbon in that forest was
holding a lot
but it's not fully secure
and many of you remember the ice storm
that came through in 1998 caused a lot
of damage to the forest killed a lot of
trees
impermanence of that carbon stock
even more important than
strong storms are native pests and
introduce pests and pathogens
like the forest tent caterpillar that on
a sequin
on a
interval
comes back
and defoliates the trees causes a lot of
mortality natural disturbance affecting
the security of forest carbon stocks
we're all familiar probably with some of
the more
virulent introduced pests the trees
don't have much resistance to
forces like the hemlock willie adelgid
which is now killing hemlock trees all
over the northeastern united states
now we're all hearing about emerald ash
borer and seeing the emerald
seeing the white ash trees dying all
over the northeast united states beech
bark disease which has been here for
quite a long time
the art arnott forest trajectory that i
showed you was subject to these
disturbances we have second most
abundant tree in the forest is ash
so those ash trees are pretty much all
going to die
that carbon is going to be released into
the atmosphere so my trajectory did not
take into account emerald ash borer it
did not take into account beach
parkinson's
which brings me to the subject of silver
culture for climate change
mitigation and adaptation what can we do
in terms of management
for global climate change mitigation and
adaptation
the objectives of silviculture are many
but the probably the two foremost ones
are to manage the forest
for two reasons
to facilitate the regeneration of
desired species
and second
by cutting some of the trees funnel the
growth potential of the site
into the most valuable trees
that's going to benefit from the
standpoint of timber and it can also
provide a benefit from the standpoint of
climate change mitigation and adaptation
i'll illustrate this with a simple
conceptual graph
so again we have on the vertical axis
carbon stocks the amounts stored in the
forest
uh through time on a forest developing
like the one that are not forest
so
in the unthin condition this is the
growth curve that i showed you for the
arnott forest accumulation of carbon
carbon will be stored in those ducts
in the unthinned situation
if you thin the forest and take out some
trees
the bunk of carbon's
stock will be reduced
however the trees that are left behind
grow faster
and they have better timber quality
and some of the
things can go into durable wood products
and so our total carbon
sequestration or stock over time if you
add the thinnings
to the
stock in the forest can exceed what you
would have if you just left the forest
unmanaged
now next i'm going to go to it a tricky
case and this is one that
is common condition confronted by many
foresters
some landowner bought a piece of
property
that the previous owners had
had really degraded by their
mismanagement
and it's a tricky case
because of the time factor and because
uh if climate management is your most
important
priority
you have a very few options here
you could try to rehabilitate this kind
of a site
with silviculture but most
forest managers would say no no you'd be
better off just to liquidate the whole
thing and start from scratch
or you could just leave it to itself and
let it heal
now from the standpoint of climate
mitigation that last choice
may be best because you get the most
carbon there in the short run
if you
clear that land and that carbon goes
into the atmosphere yeah in the long run
you're going to get more carbon on that
site but in the short run you're going
to have a lot more carbon in the
atmosphere
so it's a it's a tricky case
if
that low-grade timber has a
market
in the form of durable products like
like chips
or as perhaps biofuel solid biofuel
then
liquidating the carbon capital
would could still be a viable climate
change mitigation option
tricky question
the next question is also a tricky one
and this is the fact that climate is
warming faster
than the trees are able to keep pace
so let's say by the middle of our of
this century the climate we have in
upstate new york is about the same as
what it is now in virginia
so the climate is changing faster than
the trees can migrate the trees disperse
their seeds
on the orders of tens of meters and
that's on maybe a 50-year time scale
so they're not going to be able to keep
up with climate change
so silviculture for adaptation to
climate change would be
planting trees now
this is a departure from standard
practice here we almost entirely rely
in silviculture and in
forest management on natural
regeneration it's cheaper and it's
dependable and the trees you get are
going to do pretty well under a constant
climate around here
but consider
the trees in virginia now there's a lot
of variation genetic variation
within a species of trees so the sugar
maple trees that are growing in virginia
are better adapted to that climate than
they are
to the new york climate
well if we have the virginia climate in
new york in 50 years maybe we should be
thinking about planting sugar maple seed
stock seeds or stock from virginia up
into
upstate new york
or on the right we might even be
thinking about expanding the range
of seven species farther north we want
to put southern red oak into upstate new
york to take advantage of this this is
going to be very risky business it's a
more radical
approach to silviculture and
forest managed
forest
researchers can't really give you a
concrete answer to this because there's
so many
uncertainties involved
the similar similar
case applies with regard to aforestation
of deforested lands
so a common sight around upstate new
york driving down the highway and you
see off in the distance
an old pasture that maybe was abandoned
30 or 40 years ago and it's still in the
scrub
stage so these persistent scrub stage
suppresses the trees the trees are out
competed by the shrubs
and this kind of a landscape has much
much lower carbon stock than will a full
grown tall forest now eventually
forest is going to grow back in those
locations but again remember the time
factor here
carbon in the short run is much more
valuable
in the forest than in the long run
the
tricky part of
aforestation of post-agricultural lands
is that it's expensive
that is you have to do some kind of site
preparation
you have to plant the trees you have to
decide what kind of trees to plant
and then once you've planted those trees
you have to protect them from deer from
rabbits from other
forces that could affect their
regeneration
the question of what to plant we don't
have a whole lot of information to go on
i'll give you one example though and
this is an interesting one in the 19
early 1940s some soil scientists
at cornell
planted
a whole bunch of plantations one acre
plantations on some abandoned fields on
the hills up above ithaca
and those trees that have been growing
there for
75 years now they had 10 different
species of trees
and they had replicated plots
so we've gone back and measured the
trees on those plots 75 years later
so i'd invite you to think a little bit
for a sec
what do you think which species
would have accumulated on an abandoned
field in ithaca new york would have
accumulated the most biomass
at the age of 73 years
how would you rank them
i think if i was to
have predicted this i would have guessed
red oak
it's a fast-growing tree
we're near the middle of its range tulip
was a
fast-growing big big tree but we're kind
of towards the north end of its range
maybe it would be too cold for sure for
too little poplar
sugar maple is a slower growing species
i wouldn't put it at the top
conifers grow fast white pine gets to be
really tall
but it's soft wood and the wood isn't
very heavy so
maybe it wouldn't be like time
well here's the answer
the winner was tula poplar
these trees are huge they're uh
they're now about 140 feet tall
at age 75 so they grew really well red
oak did finish second so i wasn't that
far off sugar maple closed norway spruce
was similar
the pines
not so much
so you don't want to plant pine if you
want to maximize carbon sequestration on
a forested lands
maybe you want to plant a mix
of
maybe a couple of oaks and tulip poplar
maybe some slower growers
maybe mix in some spruce well with
regard to spruce and the conifers
there's one other consideration here
and that's
albedo
so to to define it albedo
is the reflection of solar radiation by
a surface
so if you have a high albedo
then most of the sunlight falling on the
surface is reflected back to the
sky and doesn't
warm
the surface or the lower atmosphere so
the higher the albedo the less warming
so a white colored surface like snow has
a high albedo compared with the albedo
of the forest
and one of our grad students got
interested in this and she rigged up a
system
on a drone to be able to so she put
the instruments for measuring the albedo
on the drone and then flew it over a
bunch of different forests under
different snow covers
and these are our observations
so for the open field with a lot of snow
on 65 percent
of the sunlight is is reflected on a
typical sunny day
lower for forest
you know if you just look at that you'd
say well maybe we want to get rid of all
the forests
and then we cool the climate with all
those open snow-covered fields
it would be helping us much later in the
century when there wasn't any more snow
but
um and also you you sacrifice all the
carbon storage
the difference between a deciduous
forest and a conifer forest though is
big enough
that it's smarter from an
aforestation standpoint to plant a
deciduous forest as long as we have a
lot of snow cover there's no leaves on
the trees in the winter and so some of
the radiation is reflected
by the snow it shows through compared
with the conifer forest
so my conclusion on deforestation is
that there's a lot of potential there
and how to facilitate it is it
is a tricky question it's going to be
expensive
moving now to the subject of forest
products and i wanted at this point just
to acknowledge um
bob uh
malzheimer from suny esf who gave a nice
talk on this subject last summer and i
borrowed some of his slides i hope you
don't mind but
so remember durable forest products
contain a lot of carbon
there are two ways in which these forest
products then can help address and
mitigate climate change
one is that carbon sequestration benefit
there's carbon in the forest products
the second is the substitution benefit
there's much less fossil fuels
associated
with using wood
as a building material than using steel
or concrete
much more fossil fuel emissions this is
an example that bob pulled out of the
literature
uh showing the amount of fossil fuels
used
to make a wood floor
compared with a concrete slab floor or a
steel
based floor
so it's three
to five times higher
for the
non-non-forest product
that's the substitution benefit all the
fossil fuel energy that goes into making
steel or concrete concrete actually is
the in the production produces a lot of
greenhouse gases
the subject of mass timber buildings has
gotten a lot of potential this is a
relatively new technology you maybe
aren't aware of
wood engineers have figured out how to
glue and nail together little pieces of
wood in a way that makes it very very
strong
structural materials so you can now
build build big buildings multi-story
buildings out of wood rather than with
steel
so that's a sequestration benefit
because of the carbon stored in the
building and there's also a substitution
benefit because there's less carbon
associated with the fossil fuels in
producing the materials steel
and cement than producing wood
[Music]
the figures are shown here the
substitution benefit for this
dormitory at the university of
washington
um
is about twice
the sequestration benefit but both are a
big benefit from the standpoint of
carbon climate mitigation
okay and i'll finally say a few words
about forest biofuels this is a very
complicated issue that would require an
entire
hour to give her
complete coverage
but in principle forest biofuel
force-based bio energy
should be a win situation
that is you burn the carbon dioxide to
produce
whether it's heat or electricity in a
power plant or in a home
that releases the carbon that was in the
trees out into the atmosphere but in
principle that same amount of carbon is
going to be
so uh
accumulated in the trees as they grow
back
of course the time scale is a is a
question it may not it may take 70 years
for that carbon that you released
instantaneously on burning it to
accumulate in the forest and that's why
it's become controversial
the problem and the reason for the high
controversy associated with
forest-based
bioenergy
is that this substitution benefit
may be
problematic
if the sourcing of the
carbon
is not done correctly
so if the free market is left to itself
to provide the carbon
the biofuel
the sourcing of the biofuel
and forest carbon stocks get degraded in
the process
then
especially in the short run it's a lose
situation
so what it really means is that
forced biofuels are capable of
being a helpful advantage to climate
mitigation but only if they're very
carefully very strictly regulated
if there was a market for low-grade
trees and forest biofuels it would be
imminent sense
to liquidate that carbon chip it up and
use it as a biofuel and then get a
healthy forest growing in its place
so having that market available for
low-grade materials
would be an advantage from the
standpoint of climate mitigation
unfortunately the way the climate
forest
biofuel market works now is often
people are cutting down healthy large
trees
and
turning them into chips
so i'll close with just a
quick overview of some of the take-home
messages i hope you
were able to glean from this quick
quick look at forests and carbon
management
first the variety of forests
every forest is going to need its own
prescription there's always going to
need to be expert foresters to provide
prescriptions and those prescriptions
can include climate mitigation
second the difference between carbon
stocks and the sequestration rate and
what the goal of climate change
mitigation should be
which is to maximize
especially in the short run the time
integrated carbon stock
including in that carbon stock any
durable products from harvest
third
those carbon stocks in the preserved
forest are always at some risk of
impermanence
from disturbance
by natural forces
there's nothing we can really do about
that
a fourth silver culture can promote
global climate change mitigation
and this can be built into the
landowner's
objectives and needs but it's tricky
business
the tricky business is
with adaptation to a claim changing
climate
planting
and assisted migration is at this point
really an uncertain business
a forestation of post-agricultural land
especially in a place like upstate new
york or pennsylvania where there's a lot
of abandoned agricultural land that's
lying fallow now
could be a useful
activity for the government to
provide incentives
and
coming up with the best choices of
species and sourcing of seed stock and
seedlings is
again a tricky business
and then finally
sequestering carbon with for example
mass timber business and substituting
forest products for
high fossil fuel intensity approaches to
to
industry
can be a very useful activity from the
standpoint of climate benefit
i think i'll uh leave it there and and
open the
floor for questions please don't pin me
down too much
thank you so much tim that was fantastic
um
peter i'm gonna post the poll could you
field the first question
yes
one
question tim
was was that 73 year old plantation
study published
uh let's see
the entire not the entire study there is
one paper that uh
quantified the carbon the biomass in
three of the for three of the species
we'll be publishing the broader analysis
uh sometime in the next year
great there is a question about the
clcpa which we will reserve
until after brian ellis speaks since
he'll be talking about policy
there's a question about uh in the case
of the degraded forest
what is the opportunity cost in terms of
carbon of letting interfering species
like invasive shrubs or beech
dominate the understory indefinitely
versus an aggressive attempt to
regenerate to a diverse
mix of early successional forests so my
reading of this is
is there a carbon benefit to
managing those invasive shrubs or beach
in order to get a healthy mixed species
forest growing
yeah well usually the the understory
vegetation isn't going to be a large
stock of carbon
whether it's
whether it's sapling beaches or
or shrubs it'll be only a few percent as
large as the carbon stock in the
overstory trees
so yes there may be a small penalty of
as i say liquidating that without a
market
for chips for example
um
but there the short-term benefit would
not be so or the short-term cost would
not be nearly as large as in the case of
cutting down big
big low-quality trees
great and we have a another question
if through silver culture you funnel
growth to a single valuable species you
also open yourself up to pests and
pathogens being able to flourish more
easily because you're concentrating
their source of food and energy
the monoculture problem how do you
handle this
yeah it's a very good point and you kind
of stuck
with what the particular parcel of
forest
now consists of
the the landowner wanting to maximize
his income in the short run
would want to put that growth into
the most valuable trees and it might
only be one species but then he's going
to be at the risk of
as you say
hemlock he decided to favor hemlock and
you get him or you decided to favor
white ash and then all the ash trees die
so it is a bit risky it is it is a
riskier proposition
from a climate management standpoint um
the implication would would be analogous
that is if those trees die and there's
not a market
for those trees
at this point there's a lot of salvage
going on of
white ash and turning it into
durable forest products so
maybe the industry is always going to be
capable of reacting to these kinds of
events
thanks so another question is about
alternatives to wood
so lately i keep hearing people say that
growing hemp for paper and construction
materials
has greater carbon benefits than growing
trees for paper have you looked at this
at all i don't see how it can be true
myself
well it would that would ignore the
climate benefit of the carbon in in the
stock of the vegetation
so from the standpoint of growing
fast
or growing
quickly growing
[Music]
a paper product
hemp might be favorable
but it's not going to be ever going to
be storing much carbon in the in that
stock and that any carbon that's not on
the in the stock in that land
is not storing carbon that carbon is in
the atmosphere now
you certainly wouldn't want to convert
a large forest to a him plantation
in the with the aim of
of climate mitigation
right and then there's a question about
biochar how does biochar figure into the
potential for storing carbon long-term
especially thinking about dead ash trees
good question so
the production of the biochar does
result in some carbon emissions
and then the carbon in the biochar
is pretty well preserved
depending on how the biochar is made is
pretty well preserved for
at least for moderate time scales for
say a decadal or century time scale
um
so
there is considerable potential for
taking advantage of of biochar as a
product
when forest fires go through they create
a lot of biochar so some of the carbon
from that forest is preserved
in the charcoal that was created by the
fire
but not nearly as much as is released
as co2 by the burning
thanks
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu